[Música]
bueno de verdad soy yo pero este hombre
diga
whittall fox y un hombre quien murió
era el resultado del gobierno de walter
cuatrocientos años pasado para tratar
tumbar el orden establecido bien el caso
de esta más pero esto ya está un símbolo
de él
la
bueno para la necesidad de tumbar el
paradigma establecido y encontramos que
esto es una época en que el paradigma
establecido está tribunales
está
fuerte de la época que éste servía
siempre eran esas y es necesario tumbar
el paradigma predominante para avanzar
pero ahora estamos entrando en época en
que es necesario para
romper tumbar él
el paradigma dominante para sobrevivir
estamos entrando una época de un gran
colapso del equilibrio natural en el
mundo estamos muy consciente de varios
informaciones algunos son secos
y ya en el último 100 años la cantidad
del
dióxido de carbono en el aire subió del
ciento de 280 partes por millón hasta
410 y en el último 50 años el 60 por
ciento de los animales del de la tierra
y mar desaparecerán mueran
estamos en el sexto gran
a la extinción de la historia del
planeta entonces tenemos que
tenemos que pensar cómo va a tratar con
todo eso
hay alguna solución nacional hablando
con una mujer aquí ahorita y dijo que yo
vivo en miami yo digo que bueno 32 50
años
miami de estar bajo del mar y dijo bueno
yo siempre quería vivir en una casa
flotante
bueno ok pero hay un problema el
problema es que qué te va a hacer en los
días cuando la temperatura sube hasta 60
grados para que tu va a ser cuando no
van a hora para comer porque el mar está
muerto
y además
los piratas son llegando para buscar
algo para comer podría ser usted
todo este cauce que esto es un problema
que tenemos
tenemos que pensar serio si nosotros
vamos a dejar todo eso no pensar en eso
esto más allá va
o sea si nosotros vamos a seguir con
nuestro millón años de evolución como
una especie humana
y
luchar para cambiar la cosa
esta es una decisión que cada persona
tiene que tomar en términos de su camino
pero ya estamos entrando una época en
que esta es la lucha que va a definir la
vida y nuestro futuro que yo veo que hay
si para la gente quieran
dedicarse como defensores de la del
clima
para la gente quieren meterse en otra
parte de la lucha para protección de
nuestro mundo este tiempo para hacer
para hacer una decisión y yo puedo
garantizar es ustedes si una persona
quiere meterse en esta lucha
[Música]
lo siento
bueno un error de ellos
ok pero
y algo hay
entonces él
no es que
a
para mí este paso en esta manera el
último 22 años yo estoy trabajando en
los campos del país en términos de bueno
trabajo a quien el desarrollo
alternativo fuera del paradigma
dominante del desarrollo es trabajar con
comunidades para entregar la ayuda
organizar bueno entregar la información
y facilitar las otras necesidades para
ellos hacer su propio desarrollo en
particular los sistemas hidroeléctricas
y esto salió muy exitoso
ya son y el trabajo pasa por otras
instituciones otras personas pero ya hay
algunos 56 temas en el país uno en haití
en la frontera y hay más de 20 mil
habitantes del campo haciendo su propio
energía eléctrica de una manera
ecológica
y también son dueños del sistema de los
sistemas que ellos participaban muy
fuerte en la construcción de estos
sistemas es un éxito ambiental también
ok pero yo tengo tres nietos y para mí
este no era suficiente este trabajo del
de las hidroeléctricas y yo no sentí la
necesidad de enfrentar el cambio
climático directamente pero muy
frustrado en eso hasta como tres años
pasado yo encontré que hay un movimiento
global pero más enfocado en tener en los
eeuu
para ofrecer una solución y esta
solución es algo se llama secuestra ción
de carbono
hay dos conceptos de secuestra ción de
carbono uno es tener dos centrales uno
por otro lado uno es
usando combustible fácil creando mucho
dióxido de carbono en el aire y al lado
es otro central para sacar el dióxido de
carbono y ponerlo en el suelo
grava
el problema es que la gente quién va a
beneficiar de las dos plantas son la
misma gente
bueno esto no es una solución la
solución que está subiendo mucho en la
comunidad científica ahora es para
secuestrar carbono por sistemas
naturales es una forma de ingeniería
pero no es industrial
es un sistema y una posibilidad
que está basado en el uso de la
agricultura regenerativa y es algo que
funciona en la base de los agricultores
familiares pequeño lo grande no le
interesa mucho pero la realidad es la
gran mayoría de los alimentos del mundo
son por día produciendo de estos
agricultores pequeños y además está son
la gente quienes son vistos bueno
y los cálculos indican qué
si se puede
secuestrar una cantidad de carbono
atmosférico en el mismo orden de
magnitud de las emisiones de los
combustibles fósiles ofrece menos pero
no hay consejo en los números pero más o
menos
este es algo que
tenemos que es un camino que hay que hay
que caminar por
porque hay un millón de agricultores
pequeños y familiares en el mundo
[Risas]
de granos de arena
bueno pero
en este tipo de agricultura es algo que
es difícil una transición difícil y es
por eso
la paradigma del paradigma de los
agricultores pequeños la gran mayoría en
el mundo es un paradigma industrial ya
son convertido en este concepto que
tú tienes un terreno un pedazo de tierra
supuse semillas
fertilizantes es decir es agua de riego
y después de un tiempo se saca un
producto y venderlo
pero esto es algo que
no está compatible con
y la secuestra ción hay que cambiar los
sistemas porque el pase de secuestra
ción es una es en el suelo
el suelo negro es un suelo rico en
carbono y es la producción de un suelo
vivo y rico y negro que tiene la
potencial donde está el potencial para
la secuestra ción
y entonces la gente tiene que cambiar su
relación con el suelo es una parte del
reto en todo eso tienen que pensar como
ser como conductores de la nuestra no
como empresarios manejando una fábrica
tiene que pensar como facilitadores
dentro interacciones dentro plantas
bacterias hongos insectos esto otro otro
sentido
y este es algo que hay que enseñar
porque hay una tecnología de todo eso
ok la gente de este país por lo menos
los campos donde yo trabajo la gente son
listo para un cambio porque el sistema
actual no está funcionando la gente
sonriendo de las químicas los insumos
son más y más costosos y a destruir su
suelo
es tan amarga carta les hay una tormenta
de lluvia se ve los ríos marrón está la
gerencia del país saliendo por el mar
y entonces
quien necesita amor es pensar que uno se
puede facilitar esta transición está
algo que van como el está
tratando de hacerlo hace diez años y hay
otras instituciones y tienen muy poco
éxito y el problema es que no tienen un
modelo para hacer la transición
trabajando en la base de la experiencia
con las hidroeléctricas tenemos algo
entendimiento cómo se puede cambiar la
práctica de la gente este es tiene que
desarrollar un equipo un modelo primero
seguir ampliando eso
y estoy trabajando con una comunidad en
aconsejamos las martinas para hacer este
modelo
a utilizar
[Risas]
copiar
[Música]
aquí estamos en la comunidad de los
martínez y ahora mismo la encontramos en
el huerto orgánico donde trabajamos ocho
mujeres
y para de condición que eso es muy bueno
porque ahora mismo la enfermedad está
acabando
la cosa química hay que trabajar con
orgánico porque el barco orgánico es muy
bueno yo lo mi nombre es milagro término
estamos aquí en la comunidad de los ojos
team en trabajando en el huerto orgánico
para mejorar la calidad de salud
nosotros somos los que estamos iniciando
los gales nosotras las mujeres
y ella
este es
el futuro
pero
el futuro no vienen muchas tenemos en
este proceso dos cosas en particular una
vez hay un cuerpo de información de
tecnología de tecnología pero no es
tecnología industrial
esto es muy importante entender pero es
un cuerpo de información que hay que
transmitir
el primer parte del proceso era
encontrar un instructor un agricultor
pedro nimo trabajo orgánico hace mucho
tiempo que está listo para enseñar y
necesitamos en este proyecto encontraron
la comunidad listo para tomar el riesgo
de cambiar cosas y esto la comunidad de
esta comunidad algo especial tiene una
historia muy interesante que yo no tengo
tiempo para hablar mucho de eso pero
ellos son en una posición por varias
personas para tener la libertad de
experimentar que tiene mucho interés en
sostenibilidad hace mucho tiempo y yo
quiero también decir que que complica la
cosa un poco es agricultura orgánica no
es precisamente lo mismo como
agricultura regenerativa agricultura
regenerativa está un sistema enfocado en
la recuperación del suelo la generación
de suelo negro parecer orgánico hay
gente produciendo productos orgánicos
científicos certificaron que son
hidropónico no tienen ningún suelo en el
proceso esto no es relevante ok pero
no sé qué
tenemos que es el sham en el proceso del
traspaso de información que ha estado
también involucrado en el desarrollo de
un mercado de tres niveles local
regional y nacional
bueno estamos hablando de la agricultura
pero todavía este no toca el asunto del
cambio climático las realidades para
esta gente ser eficiente tiene que estar
motivado como defensores de la clima y
la gente tienen entendimiento del de
agricultura orgánica tiene entendimiento
de cambio climático pero para hacer la
relación de entre los dos hay dos partes
uno es para mostrar que para mostrar que
esté carbono del aire está entrando en
el suelo y el primer parte de esto es
que estamos tenemos laboratorios
construido en los mantinos para medir el
carbón orgánico del suelo es el único en
el país que tiene esta capacidad
también
por otra parte es ustedes este es que
bien te tienen que estar una parte del
movimiento tiene que sentir que no son
aislados no son sólo de todo eso que
estamos iniciando desarrollar enlaces
dentro la gente que tienen este
entendimiento el pensamiento urbano con
la gente del campo y para iniciar este
proceso la comunidad quiere invitar
gente ustedes quien sea que tienen
interés participar en este proceso con
ellos por un día del campo sábado
primero de diciembre hasta estoy
haciendo la invitación de la parte de la
comunidad una oportunidad para ir por
las máquinas
también el laboratorio puerto a las dos
vamos a tener una charla sobre cómo se
puede seguir desarrollando este rural
urbana enlace esta alianza es de frente
unido contra el cambio climático bueno
es algo de información
[Música]
porque es el sitio del web punto hereje
va a tener mucha más información sobre
cómo llegar calendario todo este va a
estar puesto creo que el lunes
pero información de contacto grueso
y ustedes son invitados
ok
[Música]